[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up everybody i'm denny direct
oh and my beautiful co-host here Deidre
Behar we are here to talk about every
viral moment the best speech is
basically the most talked about moments
from the 70th annual Primetime Emmy
Awards which Dedra I'm gonna rename the
marvelous mrs. Emmy oh it's a hot fire
tank I loved it because it was a good
night for that show it was a great night
for the marvelous mrs. Mazal they took
home oh the top prize of this year's and
these guys best comedy it's their first
season ow and they already took with a
bang with the big run so good and well
deserved well deserved and we're gonna
talk about this a little bit later guys
there were a lot of first-time Emmy
winners but first of all initial
reactions of the show uh happy for a lot
of the shows that I thought deserved
recognition happy for a lot of the
actors that I thought deserved
recognition overall it was a little
boring and oh my god my button just
popped guys okay we've that's how
excited we are literally button just
flew this way and full disclosure no
Spanx today so here we are well you know
what wardrobe malfunction from the Emmys
in fact Alex Borstein and well done yes
who took home the Emmy for Best
Supporting Actress in a comedy series I
don't know if you guys saw but when she
went to go accept her trophy she took
off a long thing took off a later layers
to go accept that trophy anyways guys
like we said a lot of first-time Emmy
winners we don't know what you guys
think of Emmys by the way so please
leave us your comments on below but you
know what an old favorite took home Best
Drama I don't know it's a it's a little
show have you guys heard a big game of
Thrones that's right they weren't in
contention last year correct so they're
back this year this is this show is it
speaks for itself it is a monster in it
of itself and I think Peter Dinklage's
win again so well deserved he is a force
on screen and they're ending so it's
kind of like you know it's a nice way to
kind of build momentum before the show
says goodbye forever
and speaking of momentum they came in
with the most nominations of any other
show this year
ah but I know that a lot of people were
rooting for hand mate still to maybe
make a right heat right to invest drama
but Game of Thrones coming in right
there for their panel penultimate season
season of this and something tells me
they're gonna sweep next year - Oh
1,000% but you really never know there
were a lot of shows this year that it
was their last opportunity to win
absolutely thrilled to see Claire Foy
win her last opportunity I was rooting
for Keri Russell though of course the
Americans it was their last totally but
it was exciting because again there were
a lot of first-time nominees but let's
get to the open of the show you know
obviously Michael che and Colin Jost
from SNL were the hosts but the evening
open with a musical number star-studded
musical Christmas TV without some cameos
and guest stars right yeah Ricky Martin
John Legend Sterling Kate Brown Kenan
Thompson Kristen Bell even RuPaul made a
quick little appearance they hit the
stage to joke that the diversity issue
in Hollywood is fixed we did it yeah you
know I think they did a really good job
of using humor right to tackle a serious
issue they picked the right people I
thought even people who are not
particularly diverse like a Kristen Bell
or Kate McKinnon they had the right
sense of humor about it this was the
highlight of the opening for me I
preferred this to the monologue that Oh
100% in fact I'm gonna say it guys I
felt like Michael and Collin were a
little bit of a snooze fest so the best
part about that opening number is what
they were in it honestly right yeah you
know Michael and Collin are bright men
articulate they do the weekend update'
fabulously I think there's a huge
difference between doing the SNL weekend
update' and hosting a live award show
and 100% not that show tonight it did
and they did a fine job it's just I
don't have any moments that really come
to the forefront of my mind oh that was
so funny where is Jimmy Kimmel always
slays me you know and that's the thing
that's what's so tough about hosting
these award shows is cuz you're really
not supposed to be the point of the
entire it's not about you it's not about
you leave it right along but you also
look for those funny moments or those
magical moments that you remember right
the ones that people are tweeting about
that you talk about the next day and I
feel like we were missing that from
Michael and Colin look the last award
show that you and I recapped was the MTV
Video Video Music Awards and I felt like
we were just firing on all cylinders
being like oh my gosh whereas tonight I
was kind of like oh we should we should
take to Twitter and see if we missed
anything cuz nothing was really kind of
just presenting it
and look we're not alone here so we see
you're saying it was not funny and
boring lol we agree with you
mega movie says I'm sad the Americans or
this is us didn't win best series by I
am happy for Game of Thrones as that was
my third choice yeah I want to know how
you guys did on your Emmy ballots though
because what did you do
bad me too I did terrible and asleep but
I will say what et Online got it right I
got a lot right is a based on our
predictions that we talked about on
Friday LeAnn who joined me on Friday
yeah to predict who when who will win
who should win she cleaned up she
cleaned up so I should have followed her
lead on that one yeah we went with our
hearts we voted with our absolutely like
we mentioned guys a lot of first time
anyone or so I want to get to this part
real quick because what was exciting
like Ollie can't excuse me
leave comedy acting categories was it
went to two people for their first
season on the first show Rachel
Brosnahan for the marvelous missus Mazal
and Bill Hader for Barry again freshman
series yeah coming out swinging out of
the gate loved both of these choices oh
yeah first of all marvelous missus Mazal
amazing acting but an amazing show for
so many different reasons women being a
boss during a time when you weren't
supposed to be a boss this show is
speaking to our current socio-economic
which I really appreciated
Bill Hader Barry total reinvention of
his career yes like loved him on SNL
kinda was lingering this show I feel
like has really elevated him and tonight
took him to a new level and I feel like
also he was so deserving back in the SNL
days then finally the Emmy reward him
for something you know I'd be right
exactly know he had a good SNL run but
it is kind of amazing to see him lead
this series he also helped create and
produce it and now he's getting
recognition as this actor I think it's
brilliant mom you know I also gotta give
a shout out to their co-stars who are
also first-time Emmy winners we have is
that cool how that worked out yeah
that's what I knew the missus Mazal
might take the the Outstanding Comedy
Series when those ladies won they were
clean up and directing and writing yeah
stuff like that I know a lot of folks
are saying this is us was wrong don't
worry they're not going anywhere
I think from it yeah that's for sure
here to stay and again like I don't want
to sound like you know who did it awards
are not everything you're allowed to
have your favorite show you want a binge
you're allowed to have your favorite
actor that you want to love just being
decorated with the words isn't
everything it's nice but it's not
everything and come next week you know
we're also gonna be tuning in to season
three of this as always and uh and
listen the cast T's it's gonna be
emotional one I know that's no surprise
to you guys but they actually gave us a
lot of scoop on what we can expect from
this first episode those interviews are
up on et online.com
alright guys moving right along in the
drama acting categories Claire Foy from
the crown and Matthew Reese from the
Americans both took home their first
Emmy as well and again for roles that of
excuse me was for the Americans last
season and the last time that Claire
will be playing Queen Elizabeth in the
crown because of course they're doing
they're doing a time job right so
someone else's cast as Queen Elizabeth
right I think it's a wonderful way to
mark leave in an amazing show would have
loved to have seen Keri Russell win you
know to be with Matthew would have been
nice but both Claire and Matthew very
well deserved goddess thing I was a
stand for Oh kind of girl I was if she
would have won today she would have been
the first Asian American to win an elite
Actress category which would've been
amazing to see but she just the fact
that she was nominated in that category
was history now I'm gonna contradict
myself and I'm gonna say winning is
everything can we hash tag justice for
Sandra oh this woman she's unbelievable
when we did Tommy today was she
presented I was like host like oh please
time justice for Sandra oh my god you
know who else would have been a great
host as we saw tonight RuPaul and Leslie
Jones they presented together at hosts
they could host my Friday night at
Applebee's and it would be truly
mesmerizing I want them to narrate my
life
they are who we should truly get
rallying for next I'm with you because
also as we've seen on Twitter Leslie
Jones any time she watches anything
she's live tweeting it she's watching it
just like the rest of us I would have
loved to see your hostess show still
though Leslie and Chrissy Teigen would
be a great oh my god Chrissy phenomenal
choice Nancy Tigan Chrissy times we've
learned but we talked about RuPaul for a
second guys this is amazing RuPaul's
Drag Race took home the Emmy the big one
for outstanding reality-competition
series taking it from the boys the voice
has won in the last few years Andrew of
course has taken home the outstanding
reality host Emmy the last two or three
years but this is the first time the
series as a whole one at which I thought
was amazing for its tenth season I get
so nostalgic when I think of a RuPaul
I've been a fan of his music and his
work as an actor Brady Bunch McMahon
from the 90s and to see so much tenacity
in in somebody like him who has
persevered and
he's a pioneer he is conceptualized
television shows work and more than
anything it's just such a beautiful
commentary on inclusion and celebrating
all different walks of life I thought
his his win was one of the highlights of
my night for sure and of course he
served with us one of his iconic lines
from the show which as you said everyone
needs to hear if you can't love yourself
how the hell you gonna love anybody else
so true we needed to hear that tonight
please let us know if you were as moved
by RuPaul winning as we were saying
RuPaul was the best part of the whole
show I think tonight you know rue also
wanted the creative arts Emmys I think
the fact that he's like kind of cleaning
up here it's it's a moment it's a
movement
yeah right it's more than a moment it's
a movement absolutely and a long time
coming I mean we're talking about the
10th season of this show I know
everybody watches it it's yeah it used
to be your little friend over on the
logo Channel now it is like your
glamorous sister on vh1 if you're not
watching it you need to so when it comes
back guys you need to tune in its that
don't you just watch it and feel like
100 percent I get on my feet I'm happy
it's alright you guys I see a lot of
love coming in for Derrick Chris he also
took home his first Emmy for American
crime story Versace
you know Darren had such a touching
speech he really did write he obviously
was uh he obviously did his homework
which I appreciate it he knew exactly we
wanted to thing he said remember but
Mike - Mike ass I'm gonna thank you in
person I'm sorry I'm gonna say this more
for my family and it was such a sweet
moment you know this cuz it's true you
obviously want to thank the people who
made this moment possible your cast in
your group but think about who's been
ride or die with you taking you to
auditions as a child and cheering you on
when you got roles and and helping you
when you when you got rejected this
industry can be so brutal and what he
said about his fiancee bond made me tear
up a little bit you roll down the
windows and turn up music in my life you
know that feeling when you're riding in
your car you're rolling down your window
oh it sure it was poetry was so Darren
Criss cuz we know he's a talented
musician like I was so here for that
moment and his his fiance was clearly
kind of overcome with that she's got a
little choked up from Glee know we hear
and that kiss and the kiss he he laid on
her right when he accepted his trophy
when he's walking up there's a lot of
trash in there come on it's one of those
like once-in-a-lifetime moments you kind
to own it and Darren did I loved it
there was so much love in the air
tonight
can we talk about one of the most viral
moments of the entire night I'm still
shaking cuz you know I'm still fresh off
my engagement I got engaged a few months
ago no there's nothing to show but I am
just a big pile of mush and I think an
award show like this can be very formal
in many ways and seeing something as as
human as just a lovely proposal it kind
of humanizes the night a little Craig
when I was I really felt like it was a
genuine moment in the telecast one that
everybody Leslie Jones Lily Jones
reaction to that surprise proposal is
our reaction to that surprise proposal I
mean it really was something else and I
see a lot of you guys saying that was
maybe the best part of the evening tying
it from Facebook yeah the rest was kind
of boring but this was the first movie I
even got up on my feet well cuz again
back to the VMAs we weren't expecting
all those crazy moments that happened
there this was my one like VMA moment
that I wasn't expecting completely got
me out of my seat if you were here at
the et office you know that everybody
was just kind of at their computers and
when this moment happened we all shot up
and we all started screaming and and
just because love makes you feel that
way right
and because it really was one little
surprise moment that you don't expect
you know is it so it's not scripted no
so genuine and plus like Sony yeah you
know in there was a time two years ago
at the Oscars where we were like shook
over the la-la-land mix-up that was
shook over love thanks so a little of
hosel or the person by the way is Glenn
Wiese he directed the Oscars he had just
won directing a variety special and he
told it basically was like you know he's
telling his girlfriend the reason why I
don't call you my girlfriend is because
I want to call you my wife and that's
when the whole rooms not erupted erupted
absolutely so a hats off to them for
really kind of elevating tonight
after Glenn dedicated his win to his mom
who apparently had just passed away two
weeks ago right and that ring that he
put on he put on that belong to his
mother yeah I was a family heirloom
what does what a crazy wave of emotions
he's feeling in these two weeks
unbelievable congratulations to the
couple speaking of crazy emotions I want
to go back to one of to another first
time anywhere
guys Henry Winkler was one of the first
trophies handed out tonight but here's
why I was a big moment it was his first
Emmy ever you guys could believe this he
was first nominated 42 years ago he even
said this during his speech it was in
1976 for happy days playing the fonts
that that particular Emmy Best
Supporting Actor in a comedy series has
literally been something he's been
chasing for 42 years and he finally got
it with Barry and isn't it such a
wonderful thing to think about that
tenacity and that level of commitment to
his career you don't have to quit you
can still win an Emmy at 72 if you stick
with it and and he is just a class act
all the way through and I was so elated
to see that happen and he was just as
elated when our very own Kevin Frazier
talk to him backstage just literally
moments after he claimed that Emmy take
a look
she has to pee does she have to be the
excitement of it all how am i how are
you right now
I am grateful I am excited I am happy my
children I didn't thank HBO I have to
thank HBO ok yes everybody that works
between the roof and the lobby took such
good care of us they took such good care
of our show yeah I mean come on I see
you guys oh yeah I fell in love with the
Fonz as a kid watching like Nick at Nite
reruns on on TV land yeah and and to see
that he is still just as relevant in his
career at 72 it truly inspires me and
Julie it's funny yeah he's yeah the way
that he speaks I tell he's just such a
good dad such a good human a good person
he was so quick to thank Bill Hader he
said don't run no don't walk run if you
have the chance to work with Bill Hader
I love when people lift each other up
and support each other like that Sylvia
from Facebook saying Henry Winkler was
the best part of the night absolutely
loved the engagement was very real and
then let's see Elaine from Facebook the
gentleman who proposed was the highlight
of the show I'm gonna Wow yeah pretty
crazy you have all these amazing shows
and the highlight according to you guys
does an engagement but I'll tell you we
need some love we needed that yeah I
will give it up to NBC though I feel
like that was the show was moving along
though well they did this new structure
that actually kind of really like they
played the clips clips
bring him out open it up who's the
winner winner done absolutely yep um but
you know it's just as entertaining that
everybody's talking about on Twitter Oh
Chrissy Teigen as we know as always as
always you know at this point her
husband John Legend he's an e got winner
which means we had literally seen
Chrissy at almost every major award show
at this point become and we need to
write every because why she has the base
best facial expressions the best and the
camera wasted no time cutting to her
during the morning monologue there look
at look at our ways our Chrissy Teigen
she actually retweeted that tweet right
there of her and her I mean I want to
see a double chin but I mean it is kind
of unflattering you know she if you
follow her on Instagram she sucked up
his self-deprecating to know and she is
no stranger to making a silly face a
weird face no maker I just love that
she's never afraid to be the funny girl
in the room she's a supermodel but she's
not afraid to do a good double chin or
anything like that and that's what it
makes it relatable it's label because
she's also like reacting you know some
people some people donuts are like
mannequins you know she's like man I
don't want to do that she actually
tweeted that photo was just like this is
a setup
you see ratings we were just trying to
get a good Chrissy Teigen reaction in
the audience for the you know liven up
the crowd a little bit lined up the moon
just because John's Annie God does not
mean that they need to stop going to
award shows now we just got to keep
having our Teigen fit I'm sorry I didn't
fix should I see that her last name is
actually Tigan that's what she claims
John told us on the red carpet that
please keep pronouncing about it's
Teigen it's and that interviews also
online.com another great audience
reaction came from prayin Tyree Henry
this is during the open monologue yeah
when Colin and Michael we're seeing that
you know the diversity in Hollywood has
been fixed in fact now there's gonna be
a white version white only version of
Atlanta
which Brian is a know who's not having
no and I and you're right you could just
be stoic and be kind of like he made a
very nice joke next thank you I think
was all good
speaking of Atlanta though did you guys
catch this this was crazy Donald Glover
was in the audience as his Atlanta
character is kind of creepy character
Ted Perkins I mean
all white prosthetics right there that
is donald blubber if you blink you miss
it right there look at that can you
believe that I I think it's great we it
was like a little fun Easter egg that
only if you knew you knew I didn't tell
people on Twitter it was all over my
feet yeah when it I was like oh my god
you guys are right so you know he's got
a full prosthetics special effects squad
one on site yeah oh yeah because then
honestly then he came back and he was in
normal like tuxedo looking like himself
I mean literally look at right there
that is so insane this is during the
when they win excuse me bill hater beat
him yeah and the outstanding actor in a
Comedy Series category what a way to
keep the camera still on you what a wit
I wish he won I would have loved to hear
what he had to say as this came in that
ya know what Donald Glover is having a
Donald Glover Renaissance at the moment
he is gonna have plenty of opportunities
to win awards hopefully we'll get a
little more teddy and we don't know I
think so and when bill walked up to
accept his trophy actually we shook his
hand so he knew cousin bill was in on it
but was it and of course this is the
year where they don't put the camera on
the nominee as they open the doors right
remember those like fun Emmys moments
with Amy Poehler in the audience doing
silly stuff as there yes he's waiting
for that cutaway but we had to find him
you know secretly yeah in the crowd shot
so good work Internet yeah Where's Waldo
where's Teddy exactly guys I mean that
we're just scratching the surface
there's literally so many more other
moments that we can't cover today but
thankfully I will be back tomorrow with
another recap of what you didn't see on
TV during the Emmys and also your full
fashion recap I mean guys there were so
many red carpet looks a lot of bold last
year was the times that movement was the
beginning of the times element and me
too a lot of people wearing black we saw
a lot of color this year we're gonna
talk about it tomorrow
letting the light in we're letting the
light in you know that's happening
tomorrow right here and of course guys
we'll keep you up-to-date we're at the
parties tonight there are still breaking
out stuff from our backstage one-on-one
interviews with all the winners all of
that is on e t online.com
Deidre thanks so much can't believe we
just came all this to the end of award
season almost well actually we get a
little break and then we're gonna kick
in the high gear with it we sure what a
fabulous time for television it honestly
as I do love the Emmys you guys we're
gonna keep the conversation going here
Twitter thank you guys so much for
joining us and again we'll see you
tomorrow live for the daily Denny and
our full Andes recap have a good night
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you